[Música]
ah ah ah ah ah
a festa ruas esta rua fosse minha eu
mandava hill manda valor com pedrinhas
com bagrinhos que brilham para o amor
passar nesta rua nesta rua tem um bosque
que se chama que se chama solidão dentro
dele dentro dele moro ju que roubou que
roubou meu coração
se eu roubei se o robe teu coração
[Música]
torrou bastidor roubaste o meu também
se eu roubei se o roubei teu coração
é porque é porque tite quero bin
[Música]
an a
o
aham
[Música]
háháhá
se eu roubei e se eu morrer meu coração
do romance do roubaste meio também se eu
roubei se o hobby teu coração
é porque
[Música]
por que é que te quero
[Aplausos]
olá meu nome é matheus costa é fernanda
rosa e nós formamos o do a corda em si e
somos deficientes visuais
eu enxergo cerca de 3% em localização na
sala através dos dados focos de luz e eu
vejo mais ou menos 13% e vejo formas
cores mas sem muitos detalhes
a gente se conheceu há alguns anos atrás
na faculdade de música da udesc
a gente fazia uma disciplina de canto
coral junta ali eu resolvi perguntar pra
fernanda como ela faz para lidar com as
dificuldades do mundo visual
foi quando um pouquinho é como você faz
para ler partitura
como é que se faz para levar esse
contrabaixo na noite e para tocar e como
que você faz pra você usa leitor de
textos no computador
vamos fazer um som a gente começou a
tocar junto e pensar um pouquinho como
seria a nossa arte são contra baixo e
uma voz um projeto bastante desafiador
que nos chegou a usar muita criatividade
e muito preparo técnico para que essa
música acontecesse essa música que a
gente chama de vazada ou rarefeita ela é
feita por esse registro grave do
contrabaixo e o registro agudo da voz
sem ter um acompanhamento no meio um
violão um piano né que pudesse nos
acompanhar aqui e esse - que é mais tem
uma força que faz com que as pessoas
entendam melhor a letra da música e
também se envolveu emocionalmente com a
canção
a gente percebeu que muitas vezes não
precisa tocar é todas as notas
a gente só precisa ensino ar ou - muitas
vezes é mais como a gente pensa
imagine um desenho todo pontilhado nem
assim é um pouco a nossa música a mente
de quem escuta
ele completa os espaços vazios com a sua
própria experiência de vida enquanto eu
vou interpretando aquele que canta a
canção
mateus vai desenhando o cenário
colocando as cores nas imagens da música
então é imagine um girassol girassol
amarelo lindo todo orgulhoso da sua cor
e mal humorado é um girassol que tem
incomodado com o sangão que passa
fazendo barulho com a menina que vem faz
uma foto com seu celular
aposta no facebook e nunca mais aparece
esse é o girassol do caminho da praia
[Música]
o meu chapéu pegando fogo meu chapéu meu
chapéu pegando fogo no meu chapéu no
chão é pegando fogo o meu chapéu meu
chapéu pegando fogo o meu chapéu é só
isso
então ver se me deixe em paz procurou
outro bin down e sai voando pelo céu ver
se me deixe em paz ii liga [ __ ] que seu
chato vai gastar meu chapéu preto do
fogo no meu chapéu meu chapéu de tudo
fogo merchant é meu chapéu em gandu foco
meu chapéu
meu sonho é o pt tendo focou meu chapéu
sai sangão ver se me deixe mais procura
trato da u
e saiu voando pelo céu ver se lhe deste
vai se vingar sadak seu chato vai pastar
[Música]
giro não era gay
bruno dayanna ó da gordura da gaguez
ora ora
ó meu chapéu tentando falar com deus meu
chapéu nem do chapéu meu chapéu milho do
fogo no meu chapéu meu chapéu preto do
fogo o meu chapéu em chip passando por
aqui acordo com celular pra mim sorria
tinha xis aqui no cabo do ver se me
mandam num e meio no natal
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o deficiente físico
quando uma pessoa privada de ter um dos
seus sentidos como é o nosso caso da
visão
a gente precisa encontrar outras formas
de entender esse mundo
só que hoje o nosso modelo é tão visual
né
e as imagens elas destroem a gente nos
confundem um pouco o que elas querem
dizer e nos permite às vezes não nos
permite às vezes entendeu o motivo delas
existirem que nos leva a pensar que tem
alguma coisa errada aí né
um dia eu fui visitar minha mãe e lá há
como sempre a tv fica ligada na sala sem
ninguém assiste a notícia o noticiário
passava uma notícia nessa seguida da
outra e carregada de informação visual
uma menina foi estuprada hoje tem
trânsito na avenida beira mar
a greve dos professores
eu fiquei mal a semana toda com a
primeira notícia e as pessoas ali parece
que nem nem ouviram não perceberam
anestesiados
sabe eu e fernando a gente optou por não
ter tv em casa a gente sabe das notícias
através de da internet ou de amigos ea
gente consegue
dessa forma de usar um pouquinho a
quantidade de informação e também a
velocidade que ela vem porque a gente
precisa de um tempo para refletir para
absorver para se envolver a tv o
computador ou tablet ou celular
a gente considera telas frias
porque não trazem aquele calor aquela é
uma atividade que é uma conversa né
na frente do outro e essas telas elas
primam pela quantidade de informações é
e menos pela qualidade sem ter tempo
assim a gente pensar poxa será que isso
foi importante para mim é realmente e aí
a gente se pergunta é será que precisa
de tanta informação
será que se a gente não vê alguma coisa
a gente vai perder o vai perder algo
e como fica a relação humana
a gente acredita que a forma como está
sendo veiculada a informação dessa forma
desenfreada acaba gerando pessoas
insensíveis anestesiados emocionalmente
e com dificuldades de autocrítica nossa
arte é uma reação a isso é um mergulho
para dentro de si um alta reflexão
sensibilização
então a gente convida agora vocês a
entrar em um pouquinho o nosso mundo
fechar os olhos para ouvir a próxima
canção até mais
[Música]
ah ah ah ah
tá a at&t frio sim fome e azul e um mal
a merco o lyoto não tanto e tão desperta
uma onda que se vai só se vai de novo
nesse caminho buscando areia em seu
eterno navegar volta para o mar
ah tá te frio symphony e azul e o mal
a mergulhado num clipe dão de sparta da
que se vá
ae o sérvio
i só se vai de novo nesse caminha buscam
dorinho
isso em seu eterno navegar
a volta para o mar
[Música]
queria tanto o sentir o dom de não ficar
ae o mam ba vi no vírus mergulhou em o
meu coração
assim como uma onda passageira do
caminhão
eu sigo nessa estrada com os passarinhos
e olhos mar
a parece que na vida vôo o
o amin ngana que busco pela ie volto
para omã
e volto para o mar
e volto faro
[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
[Música]